I went to a 7th Day Adventist church
because I had one question I wanted
answered. Is this actually a cult? And
after attending the service, hearing the
doctrines, and speaking directly to the
preacher afterward, I have some serious
concerns. The 7th Day Adventist Church
is an interesting one because depending
on who you ask, some would classify it
as another Christian denomination,
whereas others would say that some of
the teachings and doctrines of the
church place it outside of that. There
are even others who would go as far as
to call it a cult. I'll give you my
thoughts on that a bit later in the
video. So, I arrived at the church on a
Saturday morning. The building was
fairly simple and traditional, and that
same tone carried through into the
service as well. Inside the church, it
had wooden pews, a simple layout, and a
fairly small congregation, maybe around
30 adults and about 10 children. Most
people seem to sit near the back. Now
they actually mentioned my name uh at
the start of the service to welcome me.
>> Welcome and I hope that you enjoy
worshiping with us today.
>> And they played uh traditional hymns,
maybe three or four hymns.
>> They started the service with a
devotional reading on the Sabbath, which
was no surprise.
>> It was um talking about the Sabbath and
saying that it's a time of rest. This
was the first time during the service
that some of the distinctive Adventist
theology really started to emerge.
Adventists believe that Saturday is the
true day of worship and remains a
binding moral commandment for Christians
today. The church also believes that
enforced Sunday worship in the future
will be connected to the mark of the
beast. The atmosphere overall was like a
traditional church. But we can't judge a
church based on its atmosphere. The
question is, is what they are teaching
biblical? So the service started off
with a devotional. Then there were hymns
during the time of worship. There were
two collections that were taken up and
there was a time when kids went to the
front and they were read a story about
the creation account. The sermon itself
focused heavily on death and the
resurrection. But as it continued, some
more key Adventist doctrines started to
emerge. And this is where some serious
concerns started to appear. There was
one mention in particular that really
stood out to me, but I'll get to that
shortly. One doctrine that quickly
emerged was something known as soul
sleep. Adventists believe that when a
person dies, they remain unconscious
until the resurrection. This is one of
the church's distinctive teachings.
>> So death is like a deep sleep. Your body
and spirit which makes body and soul one
and alive rests as the breath of life
has returned to God until the
resurrection.
>> The sermon also reflected the Adventist
belief in annihilationism.
Meaning the wicked are ultimately
destroyed rather than experiencing
eternal conscious punishment in hell.
So, you may have heard of people saying
that the wicked will burn forever or
they'll burn in hell forever.
But that would mean that they're
immortal,
which
can't be because there's only one man
who is immortal and that is God.
This is an all-consuming fight. It
literally consumes everything.
>> But the biggest concern for me came when
the preacher referenced Ellen G. White.
Unfortunately, my camera stopped
recording before this section, but I
have some footage where in the sermon
the preacher did refer to Protestants as
taking on false teachings, even using
the phrase false prophet. I'll play that
clip for you later in the video. But
they regard Ellen G. White as a true
prophet. While they would say that the
Bible was their ultimate authority, her
writings are considered inspired by God
and are treated as authoritative,
playing a significant role in shaping
doctrine and practice. But the truth is
that she actually made numerous
prophecies that proved to be false. Now,
this is the one mentioned that really
concerned me. But even after all of
this, there was still one major doctrine
I haven't mentioned yet. And in my
opinion, it may be the most concerning
teaching within 7th day Adventism. I'm
going to get to this shortly, but first
I need to tell you about my conversation
with the preacher. After the service, I
was really interested to ask the
preacher the question, "Can someone
outside of the 7th Day Adventist Church
be saved?" He was really nice and open
and he answered the question by saying,
"No, no, no. I'm not saying that
everyone in the 7th Day Adventist Church
is saved." But that wasn't the question
that I asked him. So, I asked him the
question again. And he said that, "Well,
only God can judge." And I said to him,
"Well, what about from your
perspective?" And he actually said that,
well, it depends on what they do with
the Sabbath, which was really
interesting that he highlighted that.
So, he wasn't really answering the
question directly. So, I reframed it for
him and I said to him, would you say
that you would be concerned about those
people that are in those other churches
and and that they are in danger? And he
said, "Yes, I would say that I'm
concerned for those people and that they
are in danger." So he essentially
answered the question. After the
service, the preacher actually gave me
two of Ellen G. White's books, including
The Great Controversy and Step Beyond.
Adventists also see themselves as the
remnant, a group that holds the true
teachings of scripture in a unique way
and that has a particular role in
calling others back to what they believe
is the full truth. The false prophet
took on I mean was originally indeed
Protestants
but they took on false teachings hence
the name false prophet.
>> Now there's one final doctrine within
7th day Adventism that in my opinion is
especially problematic. In the 1800s a
preacher named William Miller predicted
that Jesus would return in the year
1844. Thousands believed the prediction
and prepared for Christ's return. But
Christ never returned. And this event
became known as the great
disappointment. And rather than
admitting the prophecy was false, a new
explanation eventually emerged within
Adventism. 7th Day Adventists teach that
in 1844, Jesus entered into what is
called the investigative judgment. A
heavenly phase of judgment where the
lives of professing believers are
examined before his return. The reason
that this is so concerning is because it
undermines the finished work of Jesus
Christ. Scripture teaches that Christ
fully paid for the sins of his people
through his death and resurrection. But
the investigative judgment introduces a
system where a believer's life still
comes under a kind of ongoing heavenly
examination tied to final salvation. And
that creates serious theological
problems regarding assurance, grace, and
the sufficiency of Christ's atonement.
And this really stood out to me because
in the conversation he did affirm
salvation by grace through faith in
Christ. And this raises questions as to
is this salvation really by grace
through faith. So my overall thoughts
were this. There were people there that
genuinely desire to pursue God and the
church takes scripture seriously in
terms of what they believe to be the
truth. Adventists also affirm a number
of the core doctrines of Christianity.
But at the same time, they have a number
of other doctrines which are clearly in
error when tested by scripture. Between
the authority given to Ellen G. White,
the continued emphasis on old covenant
Sabbath observance as binding, and
doctrines like investigative judgment
that appear to undermine the finished
work of Christ. I believe there are
serious theological issues within
Adventism that Christians should be
deeply concerned about. In my opinion,
7th Day Adventism occupies a deeply
concerning space somewhere between a
severely compromised movement and a
full-blown cult. And for this reason, my
recommendation is that you would avoid
the 7th Day Adventist Church. So, would
love to get your thoughts. Leave your
comments below and I'll talk to you
soon. God bless you, friends. If you'd
like to see a video where I expose five
cults in 8 minutes, click on the link on
the screen.